foreign ministers of the association of
southeast asian nations are urging
restraint in the taiwan strait in a
statement asean members said they are
concerned volatility there could lead to
miscalculation and open conflict
but they were careful not to take sides
reaffirming their support for the one
china policy while remaining silent on
u.s house speaker nancy pelosi's visit
to taiwan
china has used the meetings in phnom
penh as an opportunity to show up
support in exchange for economic
investments in the region
we will focus on pushing for high
quality development build new
development paradigm provide bigger
momentum for regional and global
economic recovery and provide more
development opportunities for asean
countries
the chinese diplomacy was not extended
to all
its minister canceled a meeting with
japan at the last minute to register
displeasure with a statement issued by
g7 nations of which japan is a part
about pelosi's visit to taiwan
the u.s has sought to defuse tensions
it's reiterated its commitment to the
one china policy while adding it's
opposed to any move that will challenge
taiwan's status
and i hope very much that
beijing will not manufacture a crisis or
seek a pretext
to increase its aggressive military
activity
we in countries around the world believe
that
escalation serves no one
and could have unintended consequences
that serve no one's interests including
asean members
and including china
that statement is unlikely to go down
well with beijing
russia has voiced its support for china
defending its right to hold military
drills around taiwan and accusing the us
of fueling tensions in the region
the meetings in phnom penh are supposed
to be a platform for top diplomats to
hash out solutions to problems facing
the region and the wider world from
tensions in the taiwan strait to the
crisis in myanmar and the war in ukraine
but with some of the world's major
powers declining to hold one-on-one
meetings in cambodia
even the best diplomats will likely find
this a tough mission
florence louis al jazeera phnom penh